my dad was telling me because he never
gave me like a curfew he's like just
don't
just respect me yes don't come home at
four in the morning three in the morning
i remember i came home at two in the
morning he was so upset i went to strip
club my friends
and i came home and he's like wait you
don't realize i i can't go to bed till
you're home
so why you coming home at two i don't
get sleep then
he's like this is the respect thing here
and you just had a conversation i was
never late again
ever because he's like i i can't relax
unless you're home
when and then now i have kids i'm like
oh my god that's exactly what it is the
way he spoke that that was beautiful
he was in his underwear too
and i was drunk and high i'm like yeah
no doubt man yeah
and then
that's why i remember the best but he
put his leg he's like you know the thing
is bran
let me tell you something now i know why
i listen dude you you may not be at that
age right now but your dad was at that
age and i'm at that age
where sometimes you stop paying but your
body's like well you're not stopping
no no i'm here yeah yeah i'm there now
dude i was eating a chicken sandwich
with my family
in pasadena and we went to hal and ray's
and i had short shorts on
and we go to sit down and eat the
sandwich and my girl's talking and she
goes
your nuts are hanging out
i'm on the side of the street my nuts
are hanging out and i look down and go
oh damn and i just kept on keeping them
[ __ ] beating up
cause i got i got hot sauce over my
hands like i'm touching my nuts
you gotta
but you know what man i didn't give a
[ __ ] what's crazy is that like
when girls turn 14 or 15 there's
something like we're gonna
i'm gonna sled it up yeah you a dude
doesn't turn 15 and put on short shorts
and has one nut hanging out like what's
up dave how are you doing
yeah take a look at this one right here
yeah there's no
there's no thing but but i tell you what
it's because we don't get the reaction
we wanted
if i knew that having one nut out was
gonna get me oh
hot chicks no people are gonna laugh
nuts around yeah people oh yeah yeah
it's not gonna be a good day
it's not gonna be me you see that
dingling
but if you knew you hung one nut out and
that was gonna attract women
[Applause]
hang on
[Laughter]
uh dude jacob caught me once he walked
in on beth and i haven't sex oh no
no okay so he um
he walked in on her and i went having
sex and she and i were having sex
and he was young and i felt this finger
touch my ass right
and i'm married for a little while so i
was like oh okay like
is that is that what's happening tonight
it's freaky thursday yeah i mean
i i just showered up if i knew we were
getting into this
if i knew we were getting to some action
i don't want you going away with stinky
fingers but if that's what we're doing
but then i was like oh no that's not her
and i turn around
jacob right and so we had this whole
conversation
and she pulled her the covers up over
her head and just said handle it right
so i'm down at the end of the bed dick
out and i'm just like hey buddy
and uh just that fresh yeah
i'm like hey buddy and you know i i send
him back to bed
and um we had a funny conversation and
so we were at the park
and he goes to me goes you know i know
what joke you should tell
i'm like oh what joke he goes you should
tell that joke about your pain is
sticking straight up and i was like
what and he goes yeah yeah that's a
funny joke you should tell people going
to laugh i go nobody's going to laugh at
that he goes
i did yeah all right are you saying i
got a small dick why are you that
right to my face yeah but dude they
have they walked in on you yeah no no
never uh-uh
because they go to bed at like seven so
you know but they your kids sleep sleep
sleep
yeah heavy sleepers i used to get my
kids benadryl when i wanted to have sex
why you drunk oh yeah yeah a little
nyquil
benadryl my oldest son there was a point
in time where he would say something
like are we getting the juice tonight
i'm like you know
it but you know it's crazy i was when
when he asked for it i'm like oh we're
going to talk about this in therapy in a
couple of years i'm sure
get that juice tonight well what flavor
you want but we had all the flavors you
want the grape
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son